Clark County Schools responding to
pressure to be more transparent by
unveiling what is a new online dashboard
among several things it'll track
attendance grades as well as expulsions
Joshua peguero Joins Us in The Newsroom
to explain
hello Brian the district didn't give a
specific answer when asked how much the
dashboard will cost they say this is an
effort to keep the public updated
constantly on how the district and each
of the schools is doing the district is
using coveted relief Dollars called
Esser funds and according to the state
the district has 561 million dollars
that it hasn't spent yet this new
dashboard doesn't subtract violence in
the schools which was the focus of a
hearing last week in Carson City today
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara addressed
that
we have been working on for quite some
time about issues that are in the
community that are walking onto our
campuses so this is an overall Community
challenge for all of us it's not
something that is just owned by the
school district but it is happening in
our schools so we're dealing with it now
the website is currently active for
anyone in the public to use you can see
district-wide results for State exams
starting from kindergarten in the
dashboard dashboard excuse me is
available in three different languages
English Spanish and Tagalog and the data
will be updated after it's gone before
the Board of Trustees Brian